monsieur christophe pour la floride à
bord alors tu as là christophe quel âge
tu as aussi longtemps faut que je fasse
un peu le micro à 6 ans voilà un lien
savalas mais l'auteur l'a fait un essai
enfin et c'est là dedans on dirait un
homme politique est-ce que tu regarde la
télévision en ce moment oui j'aime bien
regarder la télé alors qu'est ce que tu
en penses tous ces hommes politiques qui
n'arrête pas de parler oui faut que tu
sais faire les pépés dumont pète c'est
moi voir comment ils font
à temps bon je fais moi un gros plan sur
son autre artiste la vote moi voilà
est-ce que tu veux me refaire le ppd moi
parce que moi je prends à part du nazi
t'as vu l'appel full web en mai mais toi
tu es tâche aisée le moins qu'à croquer
a tendance à 8000 francs soit je garde
encore pourquoi tu as toi quand on se
mit à noisy le sec mais déjà plus